[Music]
you started out in New York City with
Upright Citizens Brigade and and famous
so obviously some loves one person's
like location no they are the iconic
sketch group improv company that when
you when did you first started doing
television you started out doing improv
in the theater yeah how did you get your
first TV gig in New York at the time
this is like the early 2000s there was
like there weren't a lot of TV shows
there so it were doing bits on your old
show which everybody we all did a lot of
which were very fun and exciting and
then like my first big job that was like
I couldn't believe I was so excited was
the heyday of the prank show where right
after Punk'd there was like a million
prank show was called it never went
anywhere because I'm gonna describe to
you what the show as and you'll be like
oh of course that would never succeed it
was called roommate wanted and it was a
bunch of guys in a Tribeca loft
beautiful huge apartment and we were
gonna prank people who needed an
apartment people who are sad broke right
and without a home yeah we were gonna
draw out this prank for weeks we meet so
they come to the thing and we all have
like things in our ears so that they're
like you know telling us to basically
the people would come and with them yeah
you know and make them stay in the
apartment as long as we could and they
would eventually start to kind of lose
their minds because we would get really
there was a bunch of us and some of us
would be nice and then aggressive and
then we would all disappear and leave
the person alone there was this one
person who would one actor who would
just be the angry landlord and it was my
job to be like oh if the landlord comes
by like don't talk to him and then like
we'd leave the person alone and then the
landlord would show up pissed off with a
hammer oh my god this is for television
this is for television and my my role in
it was to be like the Marx friend like
the person's like to make sense of if
Andy acted crazy and you were the guy we
were pranking and he would act crazy and
I'd be like this guy's crazy yeah I'm
good cop
your friend right we're gonna get along
great you're gonna live in there I'm
gonna live upstairs don't you worry
about it and at a certain point the
person would look at me and go like I
gotta get out of here man
let's what's going on right every single
print then they'd be like reveal do the
reveal do the real and I'd be like
alright here we go haha you're on
roommate water there's a camera over
there there's a camera over there
there's camera over there and the person
every single person we did this to burst
into tears like they were in a horror
movie like huh what looks like everybody
started inching their way towards the
door and I'd have to kind of try and
corral them back into where the cameras
work is they instinctively we're like
flight flight I am beat also they're
like I want an apartment every single
Pinet where they say like do I get an
apartment every single one of them said
some version of through tears so wait a
second is this apartment not even for
rent
because I've given up other apartments
and I need a place to live and we were
all like oh no what if we die yeah
you're ruined guys way karmically we all
would at the end of every day we would
be like oh this is so crushing we are
awful everybody involved it was like oh
we're awful people this is like a show
where you play doctors it's called bad
diagnosis yes and you go in and just say
yeah and then you get them all freaked
out but it goes on for three weeks and
they get treatments that are nothing
[Laughter]
Wow you're so dumb yeah a person's like
but I really don't feel good yeah yeah
and we're like I don't know we're actors
yeah we injected you with something but
you don't know what it is it was the
blue liquid funnier when it's blue hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography